da isser wieder euer lieblings youtuber
von hinten herzlich willkommen wir heute
zu einem neuen video meiner lieben
zuschauer zuschauerinnen menschenkinder
frauen tanzen runde mäuse ratten hier
sieht es bereits im titel eingeblendet
wird es auch schon hier bei der damen
und herren wir mal wieder ein glücksrad
am start stehen einige buchstaben darauf
dass er sie nicht machen eine den
heutigen kommentar meine lieben freunde
hat der user spongebob square pence
vorbereitet danke spot an der stelle ist
mail dienst rumpeln kategorien sind also
erstens eine sache die sich gerade bei
uns im raum befindet am 2 irgendeine
marke drittens irgend ein pflegeprodukt
und viertens ein
eigentlich hatte sie make up geschrieben
aber ich bin kein einziges make-up
dingen erster zu starten und heute eine
handvoll es ist ein hobby oder nichts
mit wenn das jetzt beschissen ist das
knacken der logik award geht ganz klar
mich ich habe der sache im raum
oberlicht aufgeschrieben
als marke habe ich unten obwohl martin
bauch oder pflegeprodukt habe ich oben
steht
nein ich habe auch orden steht der promi
habe ich ja ich hab oliver pocher haben
wir bei der punkt da wird's vier punkte
wieder dieses mal nach anwesen übrigens
so dass wir die buchstaben wirklich
durchstreichen so dass nicht wieder so
was kommt wie das wir dann um das drehen
und dann hatten wir das denn dann wird
das für den monat juli für freunde und
damit ein paar sekunden später
nein das ist nicht wahr ich habe bücher
geschrieben schon blöd gesicht riss das
was gesehen nach bislang seien okay ich
hab's micro safesync pflegeprodukt habe
ich erwarte dass das soll das denn sein
und ronny richter ihn ergangen
ich habe mir mit schulden wir den raum
spricht man denn den ersten
fußballspieler da sein kommentar
dieser verstarb und die wird sich jetzt
zum stehen als erstes team schreibt das
was hier wirklich komplett ja selbst
nicht mitgerechnet
bei einer sache im raum habe jan o es
ist lee piano das ist das noch ein kind
war drexler marke habe evonik oh mein
gott für mich menschlich abstoßen also
du kriegst für esprit punkt ich finde
produkt habe ich eine art maske er passt
doch übel wichtig
bei promi habe ich effenberg ich habe
bei diesem punkt drehen und der nächsten
buchstaben die pflegeprodukte mich diese
kategorie zwischen stocker jaja das
werdet ihr die aufgabe ja darum habe ich
fuß ihr fenster okay weil das gute
fenster alte hesse komme ich nicht auf
dienstag marke habe ich viel ich habe
keine pflege produkt habe ich eine fuß
rolle
ich habe mir fußcreme sechs problem ist
auch gut da müssen wir definieren was
pflegeprodukt genau halt dieses produkt
ist was womit du deinen körper fliegst
du irgendwie den daran hat durch die
fußballer pflicht die durchblutung und
die bekommt sie habe ich felix
baumgartner und felix ihn focus
staffelstab an die wir uns kümmern
müssen ist der star tv
[Musik]
nein ich hatte halt doch was hat frau
etwas was wir brauchen ist oder was man
von hier aus sehen kann
stocker alter aber dafür richtig krass
was ich auch im verein geben hatte ja
das stimmt bei einer sache habe ich eine
waffe
dahinten wo die kerzen sind stehen bei
der marke habe ich mich ist gut oder
pflegeprodukte vaseline und kombi habe
ich hier oder brot keine ahnung wie
sägen sowie die war früher mal relevant
glaube jetzt sowieso circa beim einstand
des staates
ohne sl stopper komplett für heute eine
kamera dabei geld dafür habe ich glück
habe ich löse sind weil das richtig war
ja alles gut also produkt habe ich
einfach löschen und romy habe ich lese
ja ich habe auch noch keine woche alt
das ist ja nicht nur aufgeschrieben
[Musik]
ja ich hab nichts weil viele geburten
gehabt eine sache im raum unterhose
ich hätte lieber beim marke habe ich und
ich habe wohl und ich hab noch mal
geändert weil ich wusste dass du gut
sagen produkt habe ich unreinheiten
machte hätte ich endlich genommen aber
du hast erstmals wahrgenommen
ich wollte erst unser kiefer rasierer
sagen hab ich mir keine marken wie agip
nein du hast ein pflegeprodukt schon
das pflegeprodukt mittelalter ich habe
alles bis auf pflegeprodukte ja doch
stockt sache habe ich iphone
okay sei von mark habe ich iglu ich hab
ich das so eine schuhmarke kenne ich
aber ich glaube dir pflegeprodukt habe
ich ihnen mit einigen mir ist aber auch
klar das ist glaube ich eher ein chemie
oder physik denken ist also das
durchstreichen bombe habe ich eine
richtige serie
du hattest gerade auch im nachnamen
das unglück so wird er doch genannt ich
habe diesen tieren somerhalder oder ich
weiß nicht mal wieder mit taten anfangs
war das spiel auf die vampire diaries
mit
natürlich kriegen umfeld um mein gott
deutsche team wieder gesagt wenn ich
verliere sie haben gesagt so wie man
dann auf normalen nennt wir wollen
unsere die verluste der buchstabe dass k
[Musik]
ich frag nur noch ein pflegeprodukt okay
ich hab s 3 pflegeprodukte wodurch aber
jedem wieder sind wir in mecklenburg ein
wo ich selbst eigentlich in der sache im
raum habe ich kleidung ich habe corp
marke durch krieg oder für die abgabe
der kakao mars und pflegeprodukte habe
ich kann verbinden benutzen ja auch zu
körper ok ich hab' kontaktlinsen danke
alter des kooperativen bei promi habe
ich esse ich habe einen teil würde jude
der sage ist grenzwertig aber gut
[Musik]
p&o mein gott leute letzte runde
glücklich ist die letzte gleich jetzt
gerade weit genug
der kanal ja ich schreibe es war zu ende
sagte brown
die pflanze oh mein gott da habe ich gar
nichts mache habe ich grade ich habe
tempo
da sieht man die unterschriften habe ich
bin ich hab' creme in der pro b nach
wenn auf den kamen kamen draufsteht
es ist ein problem aber es ist ja peter
mal falsch ich bin ganz ehrlich weil die
letzte runde erzählt ist wieder die
punkte zusammen ich glaube das könnte
diesmal wirklich ein unentschieden soll
wir präsentieren uns gegenseitig unseren
punktestand
321 aber da ist sich ein halb kratz und
das obwohl wir viele punkte aberkannt
wurden ich hab mir auch gedacht ich
glaube diese eine runde diese vorrunde
die band das war mein sieg war das ist
vier zu null gewonnen der runde
an der stelle wird mir das heute videos
allerdings auch beendet weil der liebe
freude wenn es euch gefallen hat war das
gerne mal einen daumen hoch bei diesem
video da und schreibt uns gerne einen
kommentar mit vier kategorien für die
nächste folge stadt land fluss und in
die kommentare oder salzen höhenweg
wieder dabei
[Musik]